uh no sir anyway here with more the one
and only Louisiana Senator John Kennedy
you know you may get a great point we're
speaking spending a fortune you know
Biden put us back in the Paris climate
Accords why would be why would we pay
the freight the overwhelming majority of
money for the Paris climate Accords and
China and India far bigger polluters you
know China in their case they're putting
on a a coal-fired power plant every 10
days and they're a developing nation
that pays nothing or next to nothing and
we pay you know whatever whatever amount
of money we're throwing at this
well Sean there's a lot to unpack here
President Biden of course has been
present for two years
we've learned a few things
we've learned that under President Biden
the the Taliban got Blackhawks
and unvaccinated Americans got fired
we have learned that under the Biden
Administration
it seems to be focused with ferocious
intensity
on the single most important problem
today facing our nature our nation
which of course is gas stoves
now we have learned in the past two
weeks
that China has been sending
sophisticated spy balloons
over the United States and our military
installations
for at least five years and sometimes we
have known about it and other times we
haven't
now I'm not blaming President Biden for
all of that I don't know what he knew
when
but I do know this he knows now he knows
the details and I think he has a moral
obligation to go in front of the
American people and explain to us what
is going on
I don't hate the people of China I've
been to their country several times I
love the people of China but their
leadership has black hearts
China is Rich today because the United
States of America we admitted China to
the World Trade Organization on December
11 2001 China started cheating December
12th
and no one before the Trump
Administration was willing to stand up
to China and Washington D.C
and I don't want to coar with China I
don't want a hot war with China but I
want China to be a responsible member of
a stable World Order and to be blunt as
I've said before I wouldn't trust
I wouldn't turn my back on President XI
if he were two days dead and that's just
an unfortunate reality in the Bible
Administration needs to accept that
um the assertion that we should go spend
50 trillion dollars
on on climate change
which will not lower World temperatures
a symptom of a degree
unless president XI will do the same
thing and to be told in a committee this
morning by one of Mr baden's acolytes
that oh of course president XI will do
that you can trust him
you know it takes my breath away
how do you respond Senator to Joe Biden
saying it's not a major breach and
Kamala Harris saying I don't think the
Chinese uh spy balloon can would hurt
our ties uh how do you how do you make
that determination and then to add
insult to injury Senator then the
Chinese are threatening us and
threatening uh you know retaliation
against us what do we do
well with respect to what the white
Administration has said
uh this is serious this is serious as an
aneurysm let me say it again what we
have patched together from these
briefings we've been getting it's like
pulling teeth is that for at least five
years
China has been sending sophisticated spy
balloons that can stop and start and
take detailed photographs over our
military installations
for five years
sometimes we've known about it other
times we didn't
if if the most recent balloon had not
been reported by civilian to the media
with the bad Administration have told us
about the balloon I mean the apparently
the American people deserve answers and
that and this is serious
well said Senator Kennedy we appreciate
a great job today it was uh fascinating
to watch